good even ladies and
gentlemen bonsoir mesames et
[Applaudissements]
messieurson
hum welcome to the 67th international
can Film
Festival dear English speaking
Friends a recent international survey
has confirmed that the French are
considered to be the most
pretentious arrogant and rude people in
the
world
age
Soch dans le français c'est apprendre
[Applaudissements]
à quel
bonheur et quelle émotion d'être face à
vous tous quel
privilège d'être ici ce soir devant une
assistance aussi prestigieuse
certainement la plus prestigieuse devant
laquelle il m'a été offert de
m'exprimer
et quel incroyable effet miroir pour moi
qui aurait pu être dans la salle avec
vous mais je suis sur scène face à vous
que je vois normalement sur l'écran
alors que vous êtes assis dans la salle
dans ce magnifique palais des festivals
ce soir vous êtes mon cinéma
alors comme de coutume CAN sera pendant
10 jours la vitrine la plus
photographiée de la planète le diable
est dans les détails ainsi parl
Nietzsche et dès ce soir le monde entier
passera au painf le moindre de vos
orteils admirera vos corps sculptés
Envira vos toilettes cousu à même la
peau vos cheveux sublimés à 14h d'abord
lissé à la brésilienne et puis non à 15h
broché et à 16h pourquoi pas créper pour
enfin finir à 18h en chignon tiré à
quatre épingles le coiffeur en larme qui
ne veut plus sortir de la salle de bain
vos ciel recourbés vos mains manucurées
vos pommettes rehaussées au volume si
nouveau vos bouches vos bouches
repulpées vos corps gainés par des
fermetures éclair
héroïques et on m'a dit que pour les
femmes c'était encore plus de
travail des heures des des semaines que
disje des mois de labeur sinon de
torture pour arriver enfin jusqu'aux
caméras du monde entier et pour tout
cela du premier jusqu'au dernier rend
là-haut tout là-haut je vous dis bravo
vous êtes mes
héros ce dernier rang justement
où vient de s'asseoir un peu en retard
un peu essoufflé un un jeune homme
ou une jeune
fille ils ont emprunté leur tenue et ils
rêvent d'entrer dans la grande famille
psychotique du cinéma à cette seconde
même il formule le souhait de jouer la
comédie ou de réaliser un jour un film
d'ailleurs s'il cherche un jeune premier
de 28 ans je reste très
abordable peut-être même seront-ils dans
quelques années à cette même place pour
présenter cette
cérémonie je le leur souhaite du fond du
cœur alors
je ne saurais savourer l'immense honneur
qui m'est offert par Gill Jacob et
Thierry fremau sans les dédier à un
metteur en scène
unique sans cesse novateur et qui
restera pour toujours associé à
l'histoire du festival de Cann où il fut
plusieurs fois célébré et qui vient
malheureusement de nous
quitter
Luino
Federico
Roberto
Vittorio
maurce
ingson
aka
Michelangelo prenez bien soin d'Alain
mesdames et messieurs la présidente du
jury de ce 67e festival la réalisatrice
palme d'or pour la leçon de piano madame
Jane
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
Campion
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
bonsoir
bonsoir merci merci infiniment de cet
accueil chaleureux et aussi de ces
images qui m'ont
bouleversé je me sens très ému je dois
beaucoup énormément à ce
festival ma carrière n'aurait pas été
possible sans CAN et je remercie
ob fer
et tout le monde pour leur soutien et
leur encouragement j'aime ce festival je
le connais bien ça fait 28 ans que je
viens tout d'abord avec mes
courtmétrages et c'est la reine des
festivals c'est
passionnant ose choisit des films m
entier quel que soit le budget quel que
soi les stars can F tout le cinéma les
films avec une vision unique avec une
voix
spéciale je pense
aussi apprécie ce qui
ose même aussi parfois les
réalisatri je
d'être présidente du jury un jury
magnifique à l'occasion de ce 67e
festival de can plus important
[Applaudissements]
encore
anglaisette ch présidente si vous le
permettez j'ai une dernière chose à
faire il y a quelques années à Paris
j'ai vécu un moment
merveilleux j'ai passé une soirée
entière à dans avec
nilemanjhui je n'ai jamais su si c'était
un rêve ou la réalité mais maintenant
j'ai un moyen de le
savoir je dois revivre ce
rêve désolé
Nicole bonsoir je vous en
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
prie
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
buenas noches es mi Honor declarar
laa edición del festival
[Applaudissements]
inter festival inter
film bonsoir c'est un honneur de
déclarer ouverte la 67e édition du
Festival international du film de
[Applaudissements]
Cann